Okay, we got this guy. Let's see how
long this guy is going to last. Jihad
Jihad stupid. I can bet you this guy is
not going to last a minute. Hey Jihad
stupid, how you doing?
Yeah, well why do you have to be so
insulting? I'm trying to imitate
Muhammad dude. Can I quote Sahih Muslim
how he treated his companions and
insulted them?
Are you able to have an intellectual
discussion without being sarcastic?
>> could your prophet have one? Are you
saying I'm lying about quote Sahih
Muslim? You want me to quote Sahih
Muslim for you?
Yeah, go ahead. Are you sure?
Yeah, go ahead. Will you condemn
Muhammad when I quote Sahih Muslim that
he cursed his companions and insulted
them?
>> No, I won't No, I I will not I will not
condemn Muhammad. All right, all right,
let me read it for you. Okay, don't
don't speak. You're speaking like
there's a microphone by your mouth
because I
pull away from the mic because it was
>> Can you hear me? See look, you're
speaking through the mic dude. It's like
you're think speaking through your
nostrils. Pull away from the mic.
>> hear me? Oh my goodness.
Can you hear me?
>> Now that's better, yes. Jihad stupid,
hold on. Let me get it for you. Can I
read it for you? You want me to send you
the link too? Let me send you the link
and I'm going to read it. Guys, here's
the link.
Muhammad cursed his companions and even
cursed an orphan girl wishing her an
early death. Here it is, Sahih Muslim.
Guys, here's the link.
There it is, save it guys. Please click
it and hear it as a free you. I'm going
to read for you, all right? You ready?
Well yeah, because Christianity comes
from Greek mythology. Okay, that's fine,
but that's How does that excuse your
prophet from cursing people, insulting
them, making them cry? What does that
got to do with that? Let me read it for
you, ready?
Sahih Muslim, are you ready?
But then you ask Paul why he went
against Jesus' brother. Okay, you you
ready for this or no? You want to change
the subject like a coward?
>> Go ahead, go. Okay. Sahih Muslim
Sahih Muslim number 6285.
Here's the chapter subheading. Sahih
Muslim
number 6285.
Chapter 23, he upon whom Allah's apostle
invoked curse, whereas he in fact did
not deserve it, it would be a source of
reward and mercy for him. Let me repeat
the heading again because I want you to
get it. He upon whom Allah's apostle
invoked curse, whereas he in fact did
not deserve it, it would be a source of
reward and mercy for him. Aisha reported
that two persons visited Allah's
messenger and both of them talked about
a thing of which I'm not aware, but that
annoyed him and he, the messenger,
invoked curse upon both of them and
hurled malediction, insults.
And when they went out, I said, "Allah's
messenger,
the good would reach everyone, but it
would not reach these two." He said,
"Why so?" I said, "Because you've
invoked curse and hurled malediction
insults upon both of them." He said,
"Don't you know that I made a condition
with my Lord saying thus,
Oh Allah, I'm a human being and that for
a Muslim upon whom I invoke curse or
hurl malediction, make it a source of
purity and reward?" Do you understand
the hadith or do I need to explain it?
Do you understand the hadith?
I I understand. Okay. Do you agree
because I didn't read the one he curses
an orphan girl makes her cry? I'm going
to read that too.
Do you agree with what your prophet did
to justify insulting his followers, not
his enemies?
Insulting
hurling insults on his companions that
didn't deserve it and justifying say,
"Well, that's okay, Aisha, because if I
say, let's say to Jihad, you
he doesn't deserve it, Allah will turn
it into a blessing."
You okay with that?
When it comes to the hadith, you have to
take it objectively. There's a lot of
scholars
>> Goodbye. Here comes the violin.
Sahih Muslim
>> Not every single hadith is
considered
>> Quote me a scholar. Quote me a scholar.
>> under accurate.
>> Jihad
>> So this could be a da'if. No, it's
Sahih, not da'if Muslim. Don't play your
silly games with me.
It's Sahih, not da'if.
>> Sahih hadith if it if You're lying.
>> the Quran, then then
uh No, you're lying. You're lying.
>> discount it. You're lying because I'm
going to read to you what the Muslim
scholar said about
>> about lying or not lying. It's about
>> wasting my time? I'm going to hang up if
you waste my time, Jihad. Stop your
games.
No scholar will tell you that what I
quoted is da'if. It's Sahih Muslim. Stop
the games, dude, because you're wasting
my time.
>> will. Oh, so you mean for the past 1300
years before your Shabir Ali, these
ignoramuses didn't know the science of
hadith? They were closer to your
prophet, but you guys today know better?
Okay, can I now read what he said about
the
>> this? Which hadith I just gave it to
you, Sahih Muslim. Oh my goodness. Did
you get the link, dude?
I just sent you the link.
>> I was reading along with you, but I I I
I Okay, Sahih Muslim number 6285. Let me
read a couple more.
Sahih Muslim number 6286. Okay, let me
read. Sahih Muslim, not da'if Muslim.
Da'if jiddan. It's a Sahih, okay.
This hadith has been reported on the
authority of A'mash with the same chain
of transmitters.
And the hadith transmitted on the
authority of Aisha, the words are, "He
had a private meeting with them and he
hurled malediction." That means insults.
He insulted them badly upon them and
cursed them and sent them out. Let me
read three more.
Sahih Muslim, not da'if.
>> This is not even You don't This is not
even from sunnah.com.
If I now give it to you from I'm not
familiar with this website.
>> Okay, I don't care you're not familiar.
If now I want you to say cuz you
recorded I'm going to go to sunnah.com
and I'm going to give it to you from
there, Sahih Muslim. Will you say, "I am
sorry Muhammad is a
insulting his companions."
Will you say that?
Cuz I'm going to give it to you from
sunnah.com right now.
You keep embarrassing yourself, Jihad.
But I'm going to give it give it to you,
hold on. All right.
Here you go. Here you go, in your face,
okay? Here, let me give it to everyone
else. He said sunnah.com. Here you go.
Here's the one I just read and I'm going
to give it to you now from sunnah.com.
Click on it, tell me if it's there.
sunnah.com.
Do you know Arabic? Read it for me in
Arabic. It's Are we going to play that
stupid game? The Arabic is to the right.
Read it in Arabic. Go ahead, read it
now.
>> we'll stick with English. It's fine.
>> Okay, so can you stop changing the
subject? You're all over the place.
Can we now go back to the original point
because I just proved my point. Can we
go back to
>> He had a private meeting with them and
hurled malediction upon them and cursed
them and sent them out.
>> Read the Arabic for malediction. Tell me
what it is.
I'm not going to read the Arabic right
now.
>> Do I Do you want me to give you the one
on the orphan girl from this It's
the Arabic. Yeah, go ahead. Okay, here
you go. Let me first get it because you
kept saying I'm making stuff up.
All right.
Ugh, and you call yourself Jihad Yusuf.
What a name. I don't know why you even
call yourself that, but that's okay.
Here you go. Here you go. Here it is.
You ready?
Here you go. Let's see for some more.
Sahih Muslim 43. Let me just confirm if
this is the same hadith so we get it.
6297. Hold on, my friend. Just be
patient, my friend. You're my friend,
aren't you? My friend to the end. Okay.
>> Yeah, as you can be respectful. Well, if
you're not going to accuse me falsely
and say I insulted so because here's
what I can't stand about you Muslims.
>> Did I insult you? Did I curse you? Did I
say anything I'm
cursing?
>> You're not listening, my friend. Yes,
you did.
Earlier in the comment section, but
you're living a standard that even your
prophet doesn't live up to. This is what
you're missing.
If you have a problem with people
insulting, why aren't you condemning
your prophet? That was my point. You're
not getting it. Are you okay with your
prophet insulting and cursing people?
Cuz you're saying, "Don't insult me.
Don't curse me."
>> God's messenger, so Oh, so it's okay?
>> If he did it, there must have been a a
very good reason for it.
>> Okay. See, that's your logic. So the
messenger can do it, it's okay. That's
what you're saying.
And the ones who endured it,
they got blessed for it. Just like
Jesus. If you got beat
beat down,
it's a blessing You see what you just
did, Jihad? According to your doctrine.
>> what you just did, Jihad?
Jesus didn't curse someone, insult
someone, say, "It's okay, my father will
bless them." He got beat and he forgave
them and you compare that to your
prophet saying to an orphan girl, "May
you not live long and advance in years."
That's the same thing that what Jesus
did. You see why now we get disgusted
and get upset with you guys?
"May you not advance in years."
"That slave girl returned to Umm
Sulaim
weeping. Umm Sulaim said, "Oh daughter,
what is the matter with you?" She said,
"Allah's apostle
has invoked curse upon me that I should
not grow
Keep reading. Don't stop. Why'd you
stop?
Wait wait wait wait wait.
>> Yeah, read it again. Your prophet cursed
an orphan girl, made her cry wishing
that she doesn't live long.
That's your prophet. Does it say she's
an orphan?
Read it, dude. Oh oh, so the Oh
gee, now you saw duh. Okay, read it now.
Are you going to read it? "I would never
grow in age." Or she said, "in my length
of life." "Umm Sulaim went out
wrapping her head dress
hurriedly until she met Allah's
messenger. He said to her, "Umm Sulaim,
what is the matter with you?" He said,
"Allah's apostle, you invoked curse upon
my orphan girl."
>> What? My orphan girl? Wait wait. Orphan
girl?
And you have the audacity
>> what is that?" Yeah, go ahead. She said,
"The orphan girl states you have cursed
her that she might not grow in age or
grow in life."
"Allah's messenger smiled and then said,
'Umm Sulaim, don't you know that I have
made this term with my Lord?
And the term with my Lord is that I said
to him
that I said to him one am a human being
and I am pleased just as a human being
is pleased and I lose temper just as a
human being loses temper.
So for any person amongst my ummah
whom I curse and he in no way deserves
it let that oh Lord be made a source of
purification
and purity and nearness
to Allah on the day of resurrection. So
you're okay with this that your prophet
made an excuse? He cursed an orphan girl
wishing that she dies and not live long.
And his excuse is well it's going to be
a blessing instead of your God giving
Muhammad self-control. He then gives
Muhammad a license go ahead curse anyone
even those close to you who love you and
an orphan girl break her heart make her
cry cuz I'll turn into a blessing.
You're okay with that?
She said in my length of life
I should not grow in my age.
You okay with that?
Allah's apostle has invoked curse upon
me that I should not grow in age.
Are you okay with that? Because your
prophet's excuse is well Allah said
he'll bless anyone that I curse who
doesn't deserve it instead of giving
your prophet self-control to control his
mouth. You're okay with that?
So don't you
>> any Okay.
>> Huh? Jihad, don't you dare complain
about us that when we insult because
your prophet insulted and you're making
excuse for him. So don't ever complain
about Christians insulting or cursing.
Don't you dare do that because the man
you follow didn't just curse his enemies
he cursed and insulted those who love
them even an orphan girl.
Now can we get to the subject?
What's the subject? Well I we can talk
about a thousand things but you're
talking about numbers 31 and the women
and the children, right? I don't have to
take this.
Oh you don't have to take what?
>> take
this hadith. Why?
Because I told you when it comes to the
hadith
You sure?
>> Not everything is authentic. You okay.
Brother
Sahih Muslim, does it say da'if? Quote
to me one of your scholars. Not modern
scholars who are embarrassed by the
hadith like you. You just got
embarrassed by it.
Give me Imam Nawawi. Imam Nawawi wrote
the commentary on Sahih Muslim. Sharh
Sharh Sahih Muslim. Show me where Imam
Nawawi said these hadiths that I read to
you they are da'if
>> point? What's your point now? You said
you had a point.
>> My point is
are you okay with Allah not giving your
messenger the power to control his mouth
but excusing him and allowing him to
curse his companions, insult his
companions, even insulting an orphan
girl, breaking her heart, wishing that
she dies and not live long. You're okay
with this?
He's the prophet. So why couldn't your
God give your prophet power to control
his mouth instead of allowing him to
curse?
Why couldn't God change him because he's
supposed to be an example for you guys
to follow? Change him and give him power
to control his mouth.
You see the proph- you see so so Moses
was a human being.
Can you show me where his God of Moses
said it's okay Moses insult people,
curse people even those who love you and
I'll turn into a blessing.
>> Listen listen listen listen. What you
have to understand is
is that the prophet is a man. So it's
not that it's not like You're not
listening.
>> he doesn't get angry or he doesn't get
tired or he doesn't sleep. When when it
comes to matters of religion
he doesn't make mistakes. When Allah
gives him a revelation Jihad
>> he doesn't make a mistake. Hello Jihad.
>> he's farming or something
>> Jihad. farming he can make a mistake.
>> Jihad you're wasting my time not
listening. Do you want me to hang up on
you? social behaviors he can make a
mistake.
>> Jihad do you want me to hang up on you?
He can't make a mistake.
>> Okay I'm going to hang up on you because
you're not listening. Even people who
are not prophets have enough
self-control not to make the mistake to
insult people they love and curse them
especially young orphans and they're not
prophets. That means they're better than
your prophet. Stop making this silly
stupid excuse.